[Música]
A mediados del siglo 16 un joven y
talentoso anatomista llamado Andrés
besalio hizo un impactante
descubrimiento los textos de anatomía
más famosos del mundo estaban
equivocados no solo omitían importantes
detalles sobre el cuerpo humano sino que
además describían órganos de simios y
otros mamíferos si bien ves alios sabía
que él estaba en lo cierto denunciar
estos errores significaría desafiar a
galeno de pérgamo El más Afamado médico
en la historia de la medicina Quién fue
este encumbrado médico y por qué los
médicos 1300 años más tarde aún lo
veneraban y le tenían
nacido en 129 después de Cristo de
adolescente galeno salió a explorar el
Mediterráneo en busca de conocimientos
médicos regresó como un talentoso
cirujano apasionado por la anatomía y
aficionado a la ostentación
participaba con gran entusiasmo en
competencias de anatomía ansioso por
demostrar ante sus colegas En una
demostración hizo que un cerdo perdiera
la voz al atar uno de sus nervios
en otra destripó a un mono y desafió a
sus colegas a repararlo ellos no
pudieron Pero él sí gracias a estas
grotescas hazañas consiguió el puesto de
cirujano de los gladiadores de la ciudad
más tarde dejó la palestra para
convertirse en el médico personal de
cuatro emperadores romanos mientras sus
padres debatían sobre síntomas y sus
orígenes galenos se centró en estudiar
la anatomía estaba convencido de que
cada órgano cumplía una función
específica como el gobierno romano
prohibía mayormente experimentar con
cadáveres humanos galeno realizó
numerosas disecciones de animales
incluso con esta limitación sus
incansables investigaciones dieron lugar
a algunas conclusiones muy precisas una
de las más importantes contribuciones de
galeno fue su comprensión de que el
cerebro y no el corazón controlaba el
cuerpo confirmó esta teoría al abrir el
cráneo de una vaca viva al aplicar
presión en diferentes partes del cerebro
podía relacionar las distintas regiones
a funciones específicas en otros
experimentos distinguió entre nervios
sensoriales y motores determinó que la
orina se producía en los riñones y
dedujo que la respiración era controlada
por músculos Y nervios Pero esto
sorprendentes experimentos también
condujeron a errores importantes galeno
nunca se dio cuenta de que la sangre
circula de forma constante a través del
cuerpo creía más bien que el hígado
producía de forma constante una cantidad
infinita de sangre la cual se agotaba en
su viaje de ida hacia los órganos
también se le atribuye el afianzamiento
de la teoría de los cuatro humores
introducida por hipócrates unos siglos
atrás Está equivocada hipótesis
establecía que la mayoría de los
problemas de salud se debían a un
desequilibrio en los cuatro fluidos
corporales llamados humores para
corregir este balance los médicos
implementaban peligrosos tratamientos
como el sangrado y la purga debido a
esta mala comprensión del sistema
circulatorio galeno fue un ferviente
defensor de estos tratamientos a pesar
de que tenían resultados en ocasiones
letales
desafortunadamente el ego de galeno lo
llevó a pensar que todos sus
descubrimientos eran de suma relevancia
escribió tratado sobre anatomía
nutrición cuidados de los enfermos y
catálogo meticulosamente sus obras para
asegurar su conservación Durante los
siguientes 13 siglos la gran colección
de galeno imperaba sobre todas las demás
escuelas de pensamiento sus textos Se
volvieron el material básico para
instruir a los nuevos médicos quienes a
su vez escribían nuevos ensayos que
alababan las ideas de galeno incluso los
médicos que dice que van cadáveres
humanos repetían incomprensiblemente los
errores de galeno a pesar de ver
evidencia Clara en lo contrario Mientras
tanto los pocos médicos osados que
ofrecían opiniones alternas eran
ignorados o ridiculizados
el legado de galeno se mantuvo
inalterado durante 1300 años Hasta que
el anatomista del renacimiento vessalio
se expresó en contra como vestuario era
un científico y orador destacado Su
autoridad influyó en muchos médicos
jóvenes de la época pero pasarían otros
100 años antes de que se produjera una
descripción correcta de la circulación
sanguínea y 200 años más para que la
teoría de los humores se descartara por
completo por suerte hoy Contamos con los
beneficios de los experimentos de galeno
sin tener que otorgar igual
reconocimiento a sus ideas menos
precisas
Pero quizá lo valioso sea recordar que
la ciencia es un proceso en constante
cambio y que se debe poner siempre la
evidencia por sobre el ego
es una organización sin fines de lucro
considere apoyar nuestra misión de
proporcionar materiales educativos
gratuitos de alta calidad en diferentes
idiomas mediante donaciones en patreon
[Música]